[Music]
foreign
day and this is where we look at moral
quandries where two parties are in
dispute and each is claiming that the
other is an a-hole probably it's kind of
self-explanatory I didn't need to
explain it but I did and we usually pull
from Reddit for this and we'll do that
today let's go here to Reddit am I the
a-hole for telling my ex-wife I don't
care if she and her family starve that
I'm just responsible for our sons I have
two sons ages 16 and 14 with my ex-wife
our marriage reached a Bitter End when I
learned that she had remained married to
me for over three years so I would
support her through returning to school
so that she could switch careers to an
even better paying one despite her old
one paying as much as mine for years I
tried like hell to save our marriage
because I felt it fracture she played
along until she got what she wanted and
then she was honest that she had never
wanted to save our marriage it had been
over me for years when we divorced
custody was set to 50 50 of our boys and
she was ordered to pay child support to
me because she was making so much more
after her change of career and education
she remarried a year after our divorce
and had more children after the birth of
her last child uh four years ago things
got bad her husband was diagnosed with
cancer then one of her kids got
diagnosed with a long-term medical
condition then covet impacted her job
our boys would tell me how rough things
were at their moms and how they wanted
to live more with me so I went to court
and the judge moved her down to every
other weekend and changed child support
order to reflect her decrease in custody
recently she had to move into a smaller
house because of how badly they were
struggling and then she came to me for
help after the courts refused to end the
child support payments she told me that
I needed to help her and that I should
be helping to take care of my boy's
family and that's what she and her
family are I told her she used me for
three effing years so she could survive
off my money she did not get to ask me
for more to support a family that is not
my own she called me a selfish a-hole
her husband sent me a text that night
saying I was a cruel a-hole and he hoped
the boys would hate me when they
realized that I wanted their whole
family to suffer okay am I the a-hole uh
no you are
what kind of man is this like what kind
of man has the other husband who's angry
at another man for not taking care of
his own family because I can't think of
anything more
emasculating than that you expect your
ex-wife's or no you expect your wife's
ex-husband
to take care of you and your family this
is what makes divorce so brutal and
terrible
it is an ugly terrible thing because yes
normally when you marry someone it's
it's part of their responsibility to
take care of you and a wife should
expect her husband to care for the
family that's that's perfectly valid but
when you get divorced obviously you have
severed that Bond and uh thus the
responsibility has also been severed to
a great extent now parents are still
responsible for their children after
divorce and a spouse has to fulfill
whatever arrangements are made legally
with alimony and all that kind of stuff
but there has still been a fundamental
severing a disconnect that's happened
and yet at the same time
The Vow you made on the altar
can't really be undone spiritually
because you made an undying vow to this
other person and it happened whether you
wish it happened or or not it did happen
so the point is you create this just
absolute mess this terrible awful mess
where there are no good answers
no easier fun answers anyway though the
answer for this woman is to just lie in
the bed she made for herself when she
ran out on her husband that's the choice
that you made you know people are raving
about genucel skin care Sherry from
Omaha Nebraska I was just talking to her
about this and I remember exactly what
she told me she said I have sensitive
skin and I'm careful about all my
products my husband bought me genucel
bags and puffiness and geniuselled deep
Firming Serum felt it working
immediately my eyes look amazing my face
feels smooth and wrinkle free I'll never
forget when she told me that it's not
just Sherry genucel has sold over 1
million products to both women and men
Products that come in this handy Box by
the way across the entire nation you can
say goodbye to Fine Lines wrinkles and
even those annoying under eye bags
genius out will have you look in 5 10
even 15 years younger just in time for
warmer weather best of all schedule
guarantees results in as little as 12
hours or your money back as I always
tell you my talent manager Tessa she
gets these disgusting under eye bags and
so she uses genucel to help get rid of
those and everything is great so try for
yourself get gen yourself most popular
package including the classic under eye
bags and puffiness treatment for 70 off
at genucel.com Welsh you'll get free
shipping plus a luxury Beauty Box
containing two free gifts with every
subscription go to geniusell.com
next one am I the a-hole for not
inviting my stepmother to my wedding I
am getting married to my fiance this
year my parents separated when I was 14
years old my dad left my mom for his
secretary I'll call her Anna after my
mom was in an accident that left her
badly visibly scarred leaving her to
raise my two sisters and me alone
if you ever feel like you have too much
faith in humanity and you're a little
bit too optimistic and you want a dose
of um a dose of reality to bring you out
of that then just go to go to Reddit you
can go really anywhere on Reddit but
especially to this forum and you will be
introduced to the absolute dregs of
humanity so this is a guy who left his
wife and his family because his wife was
scarred in injury
like
all right this completely devastated my
mom and she was depressed for a long
time she's okay now but she's never
completely recovered I'm the oldest
child by a long stretch and I was
basically left to raise my sisters and
look after my mom for a lot of my
teenage years I was very very angry for
a long time I refused to see my dad
until I was in my mid-20s both my young
sisters were slightly too young to grasp
what had happened and continue to visit
him on weekends only they bonded a lot
better with Anna than I did and in many
ways she was like a mom to them she
introduced them to a lot of female
things like makeup and fashion because
my mom's scarring meant she didn't feel
comfortable with that kind of thing I
started speaking to my dad again about
seven years ago and we now have an okay
relationship I understand a lot better
at this age that love isn't easy and you
can't help who you fall for I'm also on
reasonable terms with his wife who has
tried extremely hard to bond with me
since I was a teenager my mom has never
fully recovered from what happened and
never found anyone else she just she can
just about stand being in the same room
as my dad without crying nowadays but
she absolutely cannot see his wife she's
not cruel or dramatic about it she just
politely declines invitations to advance
if she knows annably prison and anyway
she goes on to explain she's getting
married and she decided for that reason
she wants to have her mom there she
doesn't want this so she told the
Stepmom the uh the dad's new wife you
can't come to the wedding because I want
my mom there and she doesn't want to see
you is she the a-hole for telling the
Stepmom she can't come the way answer
again no
and this brings us back to the point
from the first one okay that divorce is
an awful ugly terrible no good horrible
thing and if you walk out on your
marriage well you have to understand is
that you are creating a world of
difficulty you're creating for yourself
everything has just become more
difficult and more awkward and you're
creating tension and hurt feelings and
all of that all of that is there now
okay and all of it is your fault because
it all follows from what you did all of
the awkwardness the tension the hurt
feelings this person doesn't want to be
around that person this all of that is
on you you did that you created that so
you're upset that your daughter doesn't
want your new wife at her wedding well
if you didn't leave your first wife this
wouldn't be an issue here's the
important Point okay
this is something we would all do well
to keep in mind when it comes to divorce
and when it comes to like everything
else
people are not required
to accommodate your selfish choices your
children especially are not so this is a
complaint that you know parents have a
lot where they they leave the marriage
they go shack up with somebody else and
then the kid is not bonding with the new
person and they get very upset about
that and sometimes they blame the kid
for it no no you need to accept this
person as your new mom or new dad no
that's not that's not your kids
responsibility that's not your child's
parent so you you can't just right you
can't
completely fracture your child's world
tear it apart at the seams and then
demand that they just accommodate
themselves to this new Arrangement maybe
you should have accommodated yourself to
your marriage
rather than expecting everyone else to
just like get used to this and and roll
with it maybe you should have rolled
with your marriage to begin with figure
out figure out a way to make your
marriage work no you break the marriage
up and then expect everyone else to
figure out a way to to to make it work
for them this new thing that you've set
up it was your job and your
responsibility to make your marriage
work that's your responsibility and in
fact I think that this daughter is uh if
anything the mistake she's making is
she's too nice to her dad she says you
can't help who you fall for yes you can
luck because it's you know love is not
literally falling it's not like you're
just walking down the street and you
trip and you fall this is uh and and
when you have someone leaving a marriage
for someone else and there's Affairs and
everything this is almost always a
gradual process you know and uh and the
the cheating spouse you know they might
after the facts oh I just I fell for
this other person which by the way even
if you did too bad those are your
feelings those are your emotions your
requirement is to is to deal with that
like you shouldn't be having those
feelings and emotions you got to figure
out a way to deal with that seek seek
help talk it out you know get marriage
counseling there's lots of things you
could do but no matter how you're
feeling it doesn't excuse you for acting
on those feelings but but even so it's
like the feelings so often are nurtured
so the cheating spouse notices you know
that they have some sort of
thing going on that's like it's a kind
of in in its infancy stages with this
other person and rather than put some
separation there because they realize oh
this is getting inappropriate I'm
developing feelings I shouldn't feel
they have a chance to just put that to
separate themselves
and they don't instead they lean into it
and then they claim that they are just
fell into it now you didn't fall into it
you walked into it with your eyes open
is what you did all right finally
um am I the a-hole for telling my mom
that she's the reason fat people hate
themselves
hello just for some context I 23 year
old female am overweight five feet zero
inches and 380 pounds that's
it's a little overweight my doctor said
for somebody of my size I am healthy and
that unless I want to lose weight I
can't make myself any better than I am
right now I had a few scares a few years
ago but I don't have diabetes I don't
have heart problems Etc I also run a
tick tock page with my boyfriend where I
show off my body to promote that Health
can come at any size I also model on
there sometimes but it's mostly
debunking misinformation about being
overweight and showing that being fat is
okay
about a month ago my mom a 50 year old
female found this page she rung me and
told me that I need to lose weight
immediately and then I will die if I
don't she told me that she can't enable
me anymore and that she won't speak to
me unless I'm a normal weight and break
it off with my boyfriend
I didn't speak with her after this she
sent me information details to a Weight
Watchers account on Christmas and she
said that that was my present she paid
for a trial for me and told me that uh I
have to just give it a go and if I don't
like it then I don't have to lose any
weight I was so annoyed at this point
and I told her that her attitude is what
gets fat people to hate themselves
because they believe they're not good
enough she told me that I was being a
disrespectful brat and that she didn't
raise me this way she told me that she
can't speak with me anymore because she
gets angry am I the a-hole maybe I could
have phrased it a nicer way and I feel
really bad that I'm hurting our
relationship but it's also not my fault
that she is being fed misinformation
about my way she's being fed
misinformation like I don't this is
going to sound wrong I mean five feet
380 pounds it's like at that weight you
have the physique of a large like
bowling ball
and again that is like I don't mean
that's an insult it's just that's that's
the physique that you have it's like for
it to be that short and that much weight
the human body is not supposed to look
like that
you're blowing up like a balloon like a
blueberry and there is no I don't you
can't tell me about hormones anything
like that there's there's no hormone
that causes that that is caused by one
thing which is you're not getting any
any exercise and you are eating a lot of
food and then you eat some more and more
and more that's how you get to that size
so yes you are the a-hole uh your mother
you know what your mother doesn't want
you to die that's her great sin
okay that's that's what makes her such a
terrible mother she doesn't she she sees
that you are killing yourself and she
doesn't want that and so she's she's uh
desperate and saying something like I'm
not going to talk to you until you lose
weight that might seem that might seem
like an act of desperation because it is
any parent who loves their child when
they see their child killing herself
they they're going to react that way
but my bigger concern is actually with
your doctor okay so you're the a-hole
but your doctor's even bigger ale if he
actually said what you claim which is
that you're healthy for someone your
size he's lying okay that's that that is
really no different than saying to
somebody with uh
I don't know stage four lung cancer that
well I mean except for the stage four
lung cancer you're in great great
physical shape like it doesn't make any
sense it's like to be 380 pounds at five
feet
there is no version of that that's
healthy
and just because you don't have diabetes
or any of those uh illnesses yet
um you will in the future you know
you're not you're not going to find
anybody with that physique who's 70
years old and that's because they die
well before that so that's the harsh
truth that's the harsh reality you have
to face it for your own sake people that
love you that's what they'll tell you
and uh and anyone who's not telling you
that's because they don't including your
boyfriend okay
so you are the ale and uh that'll do it
for us we'll just leave it there we had
what two three a holes in one no two
three non-a-holes in one a hill so
that's not a bad ratio
thank you